ok this is a pepper panic saga level 4
22 walkthrough tutorial a member of our
facebook group was having trouble so I'm
going to try to complete the level and
talk about the best strategy to do that
as you can see to match patterns level
we have to match starts out with match
fours of all the same color and when we
look at the board real quick we'll see
that we don't have four red peppers near
each other anywhere so we're going to
want we're going to want to get them
closer together and it's not a horrible
start so all right I'm just going to try
to bring these red ones a little bit
closer together and see what happens so
you can see we have one here to here so
I'm going to see if I can get another
one in the middle row and we don't have
to worry about the claw too much at all
on this one because since they're all
puddles we can't really grow peppers
that easily anyway so let me know not to
say that he doesn't make this harder but
it's you know shockwaves won't grow
these and things like that I found it I
found it would be kind of a non-issue in
the first one alright so this is we have
our we have our first red one set up now
I dropped the red onto the board it's
here I can make a three-match here
that's going to do the yellow down it'll
be a blue once in here and the floor
would be set up so do that and this is a
level i actually like because i like
doing that like setting things up like
that but you do have to think think
things through so the yellow ones
already there for us we'll go ahead and
make that
the blue ones here and we're going to
knock him out which is good we got lucky
and caught the El there now the elves
are a little bit tougher and what you
need to do is look for these gaps see
right here we have everything we need
for an owl except for the fifth yellow
and you have to try to work on that and
when you can't get this set up and what
you have to do is move things around
because as you can see sometimes it's
easier to get them in the Cascade then I
just actually set them up and you know
right here we got yellow on the right
road so we'll just drop that by matching
these blue and then let's get our el the
bluebells already here for us and all we
need a five so the five is pretty much
the same as as the L we look for our
gaps we don't have the we don't have one
right now but we have a couple that we
could set up pretty easily so well 28
moves we should be able to finish I
can't remember what the last one was but
we'll find out so we have two and one we
can move this over and that'll make the
gap we need the rain lose our fifth red
though but this one might drop right
where we need it so you know that's what
you want to do you want for this gap and
see how you can you know get to pair set
across and we didn't get it where we
wanted to but we got it in the drop so
then I remember now on the greens are
way scarce are on the board than the
other colors so this is actually a tough
match to make but we're going to do the
same thing where I look for the gaps and
if we don't have exactly what we need
then we're going to try to drop peppers
in place so like I said the green all
that was a bad man
sorry about that the greens won't fall
is fast but they will fall again you'll
see like that probably went a little bit
fast to see but as soon as you get rid
of them they come back so it's like a
fixed number of them so so like here we
have the we have the for pepper match
that we need here right except we don't
have the fifth then we have three with a
gap of the three but you don't have the
fourth only nice what we want to do is
match those to see that gets more green
ones to fall on the board and that's
basically the trick now in the process
of doing that we got these ones together
so we'll be able to make this hopefully
in a couple moves yeah now we just need
to drop this one
alright so we have moved around on a
little so now we don't have the gap we
need but we can make it over here if we
could drop something over here I don't
really see that happening real simply so
where should we go
alright what I'm going to do since I
have 18 moves you're going to want to
think this through if you do something
like this but I'm going to match these
three green ones so that some new ones
will come down and I'm just thinking
about what I want to do first to set it
out
alright so as you can see as soon as we
match those we got a couple of new ones
to fall into the board so let's try to
get
alright so now we have part of the gap
there and it's not really a great setup
let's see what we can do
okay so there we go so that's the final
match you can see how important it is to
plan things out and you know the green
part at the end is you know that's
that's the real trick is that there's a
fixed number so if you don't have it set
up how you want it then make sure you
drop it or pet match three of them
together and get me wants to drop in
there alright I hope this helps please
like the video that would be great help
to me and if you have any questions
leave a comment thanks a lot